Alan I understand you're a co-producer
on kcrw spot warm I am that's correct
okay so having worked behind the scenes
of the show what have you noticed about
building and sustaining an audience that
you've learned through bookworm because
an audience can be a very fickle thing
it can be very tricky thing so what have
you seen that's worked and what is
working as it produce your own show
taught you well bookworms producer host
is Michael silverblatt and what I've
learned from Michael is that maintaining
a focused integrity will bring an
audience and it will bring the audience
that you want if you build it they will
come but you have to build it and you
have to keep it intact and that's what
Michael has done for nearly 25 years and
you know when I when Michael became a
friend what 20 years ago I was somewhat
lost in the wilds of Hollywood
development I'd studied literature Yale
I was always a serious reader but that
world had I had left it I was you know
in the slave camps of Hollywood just
what i call the world of development and
Michael and I became friends he asked me
to work on the show and I returned to
the world of literature again and that
has studied me in all areas of my
professional life why do you think it
was that literature felt maybe safer or
more to who you really are rather than
the film business what was it about it
that well I actually feels very
comfortable in the film business but I
had not been able to turn it to my ends
and I always felt that my I that my work
perhaps was stillborn was neither fish
nor fowl it was neither neither literary
fiction nor mass communication Hollywood
product
I think that was a confusion that I was
not even aware of going back to you were
saying with building audience that they
see that integrity that's there they
will stick with it it seems like in the
beginning with anything in Hollywood
there's always this new period where
people get excited about it and then
this sort of thing happens where a glass
ceiling occurs and whether it's someone
becomes too popular for their own good
or it just gets harder to kind of reach
beyond these hurdles that were once
given when someone was newer in the
business but obviously you've seen that
Michaels stuck it out so what have you
learned about getting through sort of
those glass ceilings and those dips or
whatever you want to call them that I'm
sure occur in everyone's career I think
all those glass ceilings are ultimately
self-imposed always that the real
restrictions that I face are within me
always and that's why ultimately I
really don't feel restricted by ageism I
simply don't I'm sure it's true I'm sure
it can restrict and does restrict many
many people but I believe that the real
obstacles are always within always
you